good morning everybody
um yeah what I'm going to talk about
today is uh yet another way to share our
share the graphics that we produce you
know there's lots of ways that we uh we
all do this at the end of the day we've
got to find a way to stitch together all
the stuff into some kind of a cohesive
presentation to people and there's a lot
of ways to do that obviously sometimes
you just use notebooks sometimes you use
uh notebook variants maybe like uh hex
deep note that kind of stuff uh you
might use commercial software Tableau
SAS that kind of thing so you know
probably the first question that people
are going to ask is you know why would I
do this with Excel and we'll get into
that I'm going to show you uh you know
how this works uh you know give you a
couple quick examples and if time
permits you know I'll go through a
little quick step-by-step look at how
things work
um if I don't get have time for this I
will go ahead and uh I will go ahead and
uh you know make all this information
available on uh GitHub so you'll have uh
that during the PowerPoint the code all
that stuff okay let's jump in
okay so why Excel you know as I
mentioned there's lots of other ways you
do it you know the here's a madplatlib
one-on-one example you know we go ahead
and just put the code into a cell we
generate the um
you know generate the simple uh chart
and you know if we want to we can share
this uh notebook with appear
um
you know there's also other things you
know sometimes we like to present our
work in the uh
in a you know intranet or web app uh you
know here's just a screenshot from uh
from Dash plotly you know one of the
drawbacks of this is you do get into a
little bit more infrastructure to worry
about you have to worry about callbacks
you might have to worry about you know
HTML CSS that kind of stuff uh a little
bit steeper
um you know learning uh to get into that
to get this stuff working uh you know
there's other stuff too panelists
thought out a real lot of uh of the data
presentation data visualization stuff
again you know the
there was a little higher uh you know
cost to entry if you will in terms of
infrastructure and now it's required
there
uh so why Excel well you know Excel is
kind of a poor man's uh uh Poor Man's
dad dashboard uh if you will you know
for the
it's pretty ubiquitous uh depending on
where you're working if you're in a
corporate environment you know it's it's
all over the place there's no install to
worry about you you know it's very
simple you know minimal training if
people aren't familiar with Excel
already uh you know the problem with it
is trying to get the data into get the
graphs into Excel get them all size nice
other packages have nice features for
sizing things in a grid
um uh Excel has stuff but you know not
out of the boxer so uh what I'm going to
show you here is a way to go ahead and
try to uh pull back your results very
easily have them sized just so and uh
you know have something where uh there's
static images which is the downside of
course but there's still place for
static images I think
um especially if you deal with you know
regulatory agents he's you know Auditors
you know people that that really don't
have the time to uh or inclination to
sit around and try to try to explore
your data so you know what's a what's
great for one situation might not be so
great for another situation and uh you
know the caveat here as I said you know
this is by no means a replacement for
the open source and Commercial database
uh software you know it's you limited to
static uh stuff and this is for a local
computer in its current implementation
okay so what might an Excel playground
for uh python Graphics look like and
here I've got a little screenshot where
I kind of highlighted and it's a pretty
simple thing the concept is very similar
to um
uh the python notebook metaphor the
difference here is that you've really
got you can work with things in two
dimensions and this is kind of a this
kind of hides the code when you go to
present things but there's buttons up at
the top that'll let you toggle back and
forth between
um
between the code and the actual images
that get get generated here so the
concept here is rather than generating
uh rather than generating images that
kind of just appear sequentially below
your cells in here you still use cells
and you can resize the Excel cells to
hold your code and you use it to specify
what you want uh the size of your image
to be so you can go ahead and you know
put a bunch of images together into a
long scrolling spreadsheet you know you
could scroll horizontally you can scroll
uh vertically so you've got the two
Dimensions there and uh you know the
only difference to the code you'll see
highlighted in the Box here is that we
we go ahead and we add a couple of other
features here there's uh two variables
that get created automatically by an
Excel macro Excel with and Excel height
and what that does is it allows you uh
the macro will automatically set those
to the size of the cell that the code is
embedded in so in that way uh you know
python can go ahead generate
um
can generate cells that are precisely
size will fit right over this and we'll
see how that looks in a second the
second thing is instead of showing the
data right away showing the graphs you
go ahead and save it to a chart and this
Excel image it's just it's just
something that'll be used to you know
save a unique file for each of the
charts that you generate you can specify
you know what the resolution looks like
that kind of thing
Okay so oops let me go back here real
second uh you know I've got a call out
here for toolbar buttons one of those is
uh to draw the charts that are in your
uh that are in your workbook here I've
only got one chart in the sheet so uh
when I hit that button what's going to
do is it's going to go off submit your
code to python
uh which is going to create images the
macro fetchum and place it over the uh
you know over the code that produced it
so so that's the basic concept
um
to get covered all this some of the
details about the macros again this
stuff will be out on GitHub here's
here's what it might look like I've just
taken the same chart here and uh
replicated the code three times you know
you can either copy the code or you can
use formulas that's one of the
interesting things with uh Excel you can
locate the code anywhere and just
reference it in a Cell just with this
formula reference you can go ahead and
take here I've taken the first chart and
I've spanned two cells with it and then
I just repeated it this just for
illustration purposes you know just uh
just replicated it two times with half
the height so when you hit the when you
hit the produce charts button here you
know you'll get back something like this
so you can see that you can go ahead and
build you know a kind of a
two-dimensional grid of your uh of
charts
um moving along here to more realistic
uh use cases
you know here I just went ahead and took
a bunch of uh uh you know just used the
cars data set and uh you just uh
matplotlib it just created uh five
five uh pieces five code segments here
to generate Graphics you know hit the
button and it's going to come back and
you're going to have them all you know
kind of precisely you know size there
you get a nice little thing that you can
share with people you can email it
um you know the the person you send it
to won't need an infrastructure to get
to it so uh it's good when it works not
so good when it doesn't work but uh you
know it's a it's an easy way to to get
things going and sharing that's going to
work uh you know here you know you're
not limited to One graphics framework
here I just created some plotly things
you know you just have a different
import statement bring in a different
package uh you know hit it and you can
get you know some of the pretty charts
that you know plotly affords
um and then as a final example here I'm
just going to show how you can go ahead
and you know do some more elaborate
things I think one of the things this
was a visualization earlier this year in
the New York Times and uh it's uh you
know it's interesting just a cardigram
of the uh Cove accounts across the state
showing how the uh you know uh surge
came up at the beginning of the year
here so I just uh shown how you could
recreate that with Excel with very
little code uh here you know you just go
ahead you I've got the actual code is up
here in the state of whoops
I've got the actual code here is in the
state of Maine uh I'll show you the code
in a second but then in the subsequent
you know 51 I think I got DC in here the
subsequent 51 uh States you can just do
a reference to a to a uh
uh a python
function that's in there that'll plot
each of the individual things so you
know just lay this thing out and you can
use your your uh your
your Excel tricks to get that going you
hit the uh you can use the uh unused
cells to put in commentary and then when
you hit the um when you hit the button
uh to produce a chart you know you get
back something like this which is a
reasonable fact simile I think for the
New York Times graphic and pretty easy
to do I'll show you the uh python code
that's used here so as you can see it's
only like 20 lines of code so it's it's
pretty straightforward if you've tried
to stitch together other stuff and if
you want to have some leeway with how
you can lay out things uh it's pretty
easy way to do things I think
anyway I don't think we're going to have
a lot of time to get into how the rest
of this stuff works basically you know
you've just got up at the top I've got a
python session running in a Windows
Powershell here I've got uh you know
Excel code here when when I hit the
button you know it it goes ahead and
if I if I get lucky here it'll run
um
yeah it'll go ahead and just produce
stuff as I showed there so like I said
there's some other stuff here we don't
have time for it I've got the actual
Excel code that does this it's only you
know like 50 50 75 lines of code I'll
publish this out on
um
GitHub
and that's all I've got thanks for uh
thanks for attending and enjoy the rest
of conference